I was watching the emms last night Peter
Dinklage walks out and everyone's like
yeah Peter Dinklage and he's just like
happy birthday Martin Luther King and
everyone's like wait what like oh yeah
it is his birthday but is such a funny
happy birthday Martin Luther King Jr
like we he's he's dead he didn't need to
do it at the Emmys the show's too long
already Peter every time I see anything
Martin Luther King Jr or hear about it I
just think of the Elvis movie the new
one that came out the Austin Butler when
Martin Luther King is assassinated cuts
to Elvis Presley watching on T and he
goes Dr King he always told the truth
and it made me laugh out loud in the
theater and then I read about it and
they were like yes Elvis did say that
when he found out when King had died
it's still too corny to be filmed then
every time I see it on his birthday I
just think Dr King he always told the
truth great line